let's see if we can figure out what two
and one-fourth times three is pause this
video and see if you can work that out
alright now there's different ways that
we could approach this one way to
approach this is to recognize that if I
multiply anything times three that means
that I'm taking three of these things
and adding them together so this is
going to be the same thing as two and
one-fourth plus two and one-fourth plus
two and one-fourth
now I could also view this as each of
these two and one fourths is two plus
one-fourth plus 2 plus one-fourth plus
two plus one-fourth all I did is I broke
up that each of the two and one fourths
into a two plus one-fourth and then what
I could do is I could add the whole
number parts two plus two plus two is
going to be equal to six and then if I
were to take 1/4 plus 1/4 plus 1/4 how
many fourths do I now have I have three
fourths so it's going to be six plus
three fourths or I could write this as 6
and 3/4 now another way that we could
have approached this is we could have
rewritten 2 and 1/4 I could have
rewritten that as the same thing as two
is is 8/4 8/4 is the same thing as two
plus 1/4 and then I'm multiplying that
whole thing times 3 and so this is going
to be the same thing as 9 fourths 8/4
plus 1/4 is 9 fourths times 3 and so we
could say hey that's just going to be
equal to 9 fourths plus 9/4 plus nine
fourths which would be equal to what
well I have this is going to be nine
plus nine plus nine fourths which is
going to be equal to 27 fourths now you
might be saying hey these look like they
are different but you could check this
six is equal to how many fourths so 6 is
equal to 24 fourths 24 fourths
Plus 3/4 which is exactly equal to 27
fourths and we are done